Good morning, so our scripture reading
is in the worship guide, if you flip it around.
It's actually a few passages
so that you don't have to flip between my reading.
They're all together.
And we're looking at when Paul was traveling to Ephesus.
He had Priscilla and Aquila,
you may remember those rhyming names with him.
And so we're gonna start in Acts 18
versus 19 through 21.
And let's listen closely because this is God's word.
And they came to Ephesus and he left them there,
but he himself went into the synagogue
and reasoned with the Jews.
When they asked him to stay for a longer period,
he declined.
But on taking leave of them, he said,
I will return to you if God wills.
And he set sail from Ephesus.
And then our next passage is in chapter 19
versus eight through 10.
And this is when Paul returns to Ephesus
because the Lord did will it and he did return.
So we pick up there.
And he entered the synagogue and for three months
he spoke boldly reasoning and persuading them
about the kingdom of God.
But when some became stubborn and continued in unbelief,
speaking evil of the way before the congregation,
he withdrew from them and took the disciples with him,
reasoning daily in the hall of Tyrannus.
This continued for two years so that all the residents
of Asia heard the word of the Lord, both Jews and Greeks.
And then our last passage is in Ephesians one,
one through two.
And this is the greeting that Paul sends to those
that he had met and known the church in Ephesus.
Paul, an apostle of Christ Jesus by the will of God
to the saints who are in Ephesus
and are faithful in Christ Jesus.
Grace to you and peace from God our Father
and the Lord Jesus Christ.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray together once again as we come to God's word.
Lord as the rain and snow come down from heaven
and do not return there, but what are the earth?
Making it bring forth and sprout.
So shall your word be that goes out from your mouth.
It shall not return to you empty,
but it shall accomplish that which you purpose
and it shall succeed in the thing for which you sent it.
So as we come now to your word,
I pray that you would fulfill your purposes
for your glory.
Pray this in Jesus' name, amen.
So do have your Bibles open there at Ephesians chapter one
and you can refer back to those passages in Acts
because we will look at those as well.
But just as we get started,
I wonder if you have any go-to movies.
When you're not gonna watch a new one
but you just want something
that's an old familiar favorite,
Julia and I, we've got sort of different genres
that we like but we've come to the point
of certain movies that we really agree
that we want to watch this together for the 15th time
and I'd say at the top on that list
is probably the Born series.
You familiar with that?
So the series about Jason Born.
It begins with the movie, The Born Identity
and it's all about this man
who is a highly trained assassin
but he's suffering from dementia.
He has no idea who he is.
He just, he wakes up
and he's got all these skills
from this prior training that he has
but he's got this restlessness in him
until he finds who he truly is.
So the kind of point of the movie
is this search that he has to find his true identity.
I don't think it'd be a shock to any of us
to say that the search for identity
is a major theme in Western culture today
and it's something that a lot of people
are confused about, who they are.
One of the main places that we have been told to look
for years, if not decades now
is that we will find ourselves by looking within.
It is by looking within ourselves
that we are to find our authentic selves
and then after we discover who we truly are,
we're then called to, you've heard the mantra,
be true to yourself.
We're called to be true to ourselves.
At least that's what our culture tells us.
And then once you are true to yourself,
you are to express that self to the world around you.
And it's gotten to the point where
how you self-identify doesn't even have to line up
with objective reality because we've heard that so much
that the true you is found within
and how you identify yourself.
Ironically, this kind of search
for personal identity seems to be heavily influenced
by the culture around us.
It's supposed to be personal and by looking within
but we look around us for our cues
as to what the sort of thing we're supposed to find
when we look within ourselves.
And so that's then tied with the search
for what group we identify with
and what does it mean to fit in
with the acceptable norms of that group
that I want to be part of
or that I feel that I am a part of.
And so you have this restless pursuit
that's happening in the world around us,
particularly in Western culture today.
And that search, needless to say, does not satisfy
and it does not bring peace.
It is unfulfilling and it brings about hostility
and division between people,
between these different group identities in society.
But this morning I want us to see
where true identity can be found.
We're looking together at this introduction
to the book of Ephesians.
And at first glance it seems to just simply tell us
like this is who the letter is from, it's from Paul,
here's who the letter is to, it's to the Ephesians.
But when you take a closer look at how they are identified
it tells us something about our own identity
or where we are to find our identity as followers of Jesus.
Okay, so we'll look at that together.
Where our identity is to be found
and then some of the implications of that.
So first of all, where is our identity to be found?
Okay, so Paul's letter, it's gonna make its way to Ephesus
and from there the letter is going to go
throughout the whole region.
It's written as a kind of circular letter.
As you read through it, compared to say other letters
like I don't know, first Corinthians,
there's not as much personal information shared there.
So the kind of consensus is it goes to Ephesus
but it's not intended for Ephesus alone
but the church at large right from the start.
So any church can benefit from this
and I know we can as well.
And it makes sense that it is connected
to the church at Ephesus.
Like why is it listed to Ephesus here?
Well, Ephesus was an important city
that kind of served as a hub for the whole of Asia Minor,
the kind of region that it was in.
When people hear that Julia and I lived in England,
there's certain things that come up in conversation
almost every single time.
And one of them is either later in the conversation,
they just assume that we told them we are from London
or we lived in London.
Like as though England and London
is just a synonym of each other.
Or the question is how close do you live to London
or did you live to London?
And the reason why that is,
it's just an obvious reference point
that people have some familiarity with.
And so people in conversation, polite conversation,
they can bring up London,
given how well known it is as a city.
And Ephesus is that kind of city
in that region of the Roman Empire.
It's the third largest city at the time.
It is a port city, so it is a kind of economic hub.
So if you're gonna trade in Asia Minor,
you go through Ephesus.
Not only that, it was a religious hub.
It was the center of the worship of Artemis specifically.
There were some Jews there,
but it was most known for the worship of Artemis or Diana.
It was home to one of the wonders of the world,
the temple of Artemis.
And at a kind of local level,
shrines were produced that people could purchase
and have in their own homes.
And so it was so tied,
this worship of Artemis was so tied
to the culture of Ephesus
that Artemis was called Artemis of the Ephesians.
People saw it as being tied to their identity.
So to renounce your idolatry, your worship of Artemis,
and to give allegiance to Christ and him alone
would totally go against the grain of that culture
and yet astonishingly,
what we read in Acts earlier was that Ephesus became a hub
for the advancement of the gospel through that region.
You read that in Acts chapter 18 and 19.
We read about how Paul and others traveled into Ephesus
and they preached the gospel there.
They began making disciples.
They started off in the synagogue,
but it wasn't long before they moved into the hall of Tyrannus.
And from there, the gospel is just emanating
out through the city
and lives are being changed dramatically.
And it emanates not only throughout the city,
but then from the city to other areas across the region.
And the gospel traveled so far
that it even said in Acts chapter 19 and verse 10
that all the residents of Asia heard the word of the Lord,
both Jews and Greeks.
And it doesn't seem to be that all the residents of Asia
made a trip to Ephesus to hear the famed apostle Paul preach.
What seems to happen in the flow when you read the passage
is that the gospel is going out from Ephesus
through those who heard at Ephesus to other places.
And I'd love to get into that further,
but just as a side note, wouldn't it be amazing
if that is what the Lord did among us here?
If it could be said of even just North Jefferson County,
the word of the Lord went out to all the residents
of North Jefferson and areas beyond.
Well, what happened here was remarkable.
There's no doubt about that, but it wasn't easy.
To say that there was this amazing gospel work there,
didn't mean that there was not opposition.
There was opposition from the start.
And when people's lives were changed dramatically,
one of the hilarious things that happens
is it begins to affect the local economy.
So if part of the local trade was selling these shrines
of Artemis, well, when people stopped buying those,
well, it's gonna hurt their business.
And we even read about people who had these like magic books
that were part of their worship,
and they went and burnt those up as well.
So some local craftsmen got together
and they started stirring people up against Paul
and his coworkers.
And it got to the point where they got this mob together
and they drag some of Paul's coworkers to a local stadium.
And this mob is there in that stadium together.
So if you watched the Alabama and Georgia game last night,
you got some idea of what we're talking about here,
minus some of the lights and all the rest.
So you got this stadium, but what are people chanting?
It's not Roll Tide or anything else.
They are chanting, great is Artemis of the Ephesians,
over and over in its roaring and the cultures speaking together
in one voice and to say anything different
would have been really, really hard.
So where is identity to be found?
Well, it's not to be found in Ephesus.
The pressure to conform to culture there
was literally deafening.
And I would say that that is true in our day as well.
Is that not the case?
There's a pressure to conform.
We are surrounded by cultural currents
that will pull us away from Christ
if we are not intentionally following Him
in the opposite direction.
And if you don't feel the pull of those currents
and may just be that you are drifting
with the culture around you.
Now this can be confusing in America
and maybe Alabama specifically or the Bible Belt
because Christianity and culture can be so mixed together.
It's hard to pick out which one is which.
In Ephesus it might have looked like,
I don't know if you sort of mixed the two,
having a crucifix up in one room
and then I don't know a shrine to Artemis in the next,
thinking you could sort of play it both ways.
In Alabama it might look like,
I don't know believing that Jesus will save your soul
but He really doesn't care about what you do
with your body because you're just supposed
to be true to yourself, right?
See here those two,
the cultural current pulling you
while at the same time wanting to have a bit of Jesus
in there too.
And by the way, this isn't a right thing
or a left thing either.
This can be found on all sides of the political aisle
or the sort of the cultural things
that get tied up into those two categories.
So we cannot look to our culture for our identity.
So where do we look?
Where can it be found?
Well it is found in Christ.
So yes, so these believers are in Ephesus, verse one,
but they are also faithful.
Notice these words in Christ, Jesus.
And those two words in Christ or in Christ Jesus
are incredibly important.
This is a major theme that stretches right the way
throughout the New Testament,
especially in Paul's letters
and within Paul's letters,
especially the book of Ephesians.
We're gonna see this over and over throughout the book.
So we need to hear what the Lord is saying
by telling us about what it means to be in Christ.
And the doctrine that these two words point us to
being in Christ is traditionally referred to
as our union with Christ.
It's kind of in recent years
that people have started talking more
about our identity in Christ,
perhaps in response to what we're hearing in our culture.
But traditionally we've thought
about our union with Christ.
So what does that mean?
What is union with Christ?
It can be tricky to define,
I'll just say that from the start.
It's been described along these lines.
So listen carefully.
It is a close living spiritual union
between Christ and his people.
And from this union flows life,
blessing and salvation.
I'll say it again.
It's a close living spiritual union
between Christ and his people.
And from this union with him
flows our life, blessings and salvation.
Or to put more simply,
to be united to Christ is to have your life
bound up with his and to receive all the good
that flows from that.
It's to have died with him
and to be risen with him.
To have your life bound to his.
And several metaphors are used in scripture
and maybe these pictures help us to understand better
than kind of trying to define it.
One is Jesus in John 15.
I am divine, you are the branches, right?
That's a living relationship
between the Lord and his people.
Colossians chapter one and verse 18
as other places in scripture.
He is the body of the church,
or no, sorry, he is the head of the church
and we are the body of the church, right?
So there's a living relationship
between the head and the body.
Here in Ephesians, in Ephesians chapter five,
you see the marital union of a husband and wife
when two become one,
that is there as a picture of Christ
and his church of our union with him.
So who we are, in other words,
is vitally connected to who he is
if we are in Christ.
And that is distinct from our old selves,
our previous identity.
Our old self died with Christ.
And then we are united to him
and in that union we now have new life in him.
Paul said it this way in Galatians chapter two
and verse 20, I am, this is who I am,
crucified with Christ.
Nevertheless, I live yet not I,
but Christ lives in me.
This isn't just true of our relationship
with Christ personally, but also collectively.
So this isn't just a letter to an individual,
this is a letter to the church.
So our union with Jesus brings about communion
with one another, right?
We're brought into this body.
If you are in Jesus,
you are part of a new community
that he is creating called the church.
So this book shows us what it means
to be part of his church, his body.
So our identity is not to be found in the world,
but in Christ.
But secondly, I want us to see this.
So if it's to be found in Christ,
we then have to ask the question,
well, who are we in Christ then?
I'm still not sure who it is, we are.
So I'll draw our attention to a couple of things
about our identity that are true of us in Jesus.
So first of all, in Christ, we are saints.
So did you see that?
In verse one, Paul is writing to the saints.
So what does it mean?
Well, the word means set apart, consecrated, holy.
It's what we saw kind of about the world a minute ago
that we've been separated from the world.
So saints are in the world, but no longer of it,
we are set apart.
But who can this really be said of saints?
Like saints is another one of those confusing words
that's kind of thrown around sometimes
and it always never means what it actually means
in scripture.
So we might think of saints as being,
I don't know, that heroes of church history
who are in heaven, ready to help us in our time of needs.
Maybe you grew up thinking or hearing of saints
in that way.
There's some who believe,
there's a kind of saint for every occasion
and I've gone online to see just how many different
specializations saints have.
And I stopped once I got halfway through the bees, right?
Cause there was literally a saint for bees.
There was a saint for bookkeeping.
There was a saint for bridges and the list
went on and on and on.
That's not what we have here.
It's also used to describe somebody who's just
patiently puts up with a lot.
I don't know how in the world she deals with those children.
She really is a saint.
I know I use it from time to time.
But biblically speaking, the category of saint
is not a kind of, it's not the VIP section of Christians.
It is a term that is applied to every Christian.
If you are in Christ, you are a saint.
You might think, well, if you knew some of the things
that I've done in my life, you would not call me a saint.
But let me repeat, if you are in Christ,
that is exactly who you are.
I'm gonna take that a step further.
Around 40 times in the New Testament,
Paul refers to Christians as saints
as those who've been made holy.
How many times does Paul refer to Christians
to those who are in Christ as sinners?
The answer is zero, not one time.
Now to be fair, there is one time in the New Testament
where James refers to backsliding Christians
who were living as though they were not believers
as sinners descriptively, like they are sinning,
so they're sinners, like so, if you say that,
don't feel bad that you've said that at some point.
But nonetheless, it's not talking about their identity.
If you are in Christ, it is true to say
that you were a sinner.
That's true of all of us.
You were a sinner, for sure, me too.
It's true to say that even in Christ,
even as a Christian, you still struggle with sin
on a daily basis, yes, but hear me,
that is no longer your identity.
If you are in Christ, you have categorically been moved
from sinner to saint.
That is your God-given identity.
And the Christian life is simply learning to live
in light of that new identity that has been given us
in Jesus, and that's that kind of faithfulness
that we see there in verse one when they are,
they're faithful in Christ Jesus.
They've been set apart, and that's coming through
in the way they're living now.
Here's the deal, in Jesus' death,
he's already done everything to completely
cleanse his people from their sin.
So the question is, are you in him, or are you not?
If you're in Christ, you're no longer defined by your sin,
but by your savior.
In other words, in him, you're a saint.
But also, who else are we in him?
We are children of God.
So notice what he says in verse two,
grace to you and peace from God our Father
and the Lord Jesus Christ.
Mark those two words, our Father.
If you're in Christ, you can say he is my Father.
God is my heavenly Father.
It isn't a controversial statement to say
that our families of origin profoundly shape our lives.
It impacts the way we view ourselves,
it impacts the way we interact with the world around us,
and that's true positively, but I'd imagine
our minds didn't first go to the positives,
or at least for many of us, it can impact us negatively
as well, and for all of us it's probably a bit of both.
It's an incredibly complex thing,
and it varies from family to family,
and person to person.
But here's this, if you are in Christ,
you are no longer defined by your family of origin.
You're no longer defined by your background.
You are first and foremost a child of God.
However, you are treated by earthly parents,
whatever you were told.
If you are in Christ, you have a heavenly Father
who loves you more than you could possibly know
and will care for you and provide all that you need.
His home is a home of grace and peace.
So, however you feel in Christ,
you can know that you belong to your heavenly Father.
So who are we?
Who are you?
If your faith is in Christ, if you're united to Him,
you are His, you belong to Him as a saint, as a child of God.
But lastly, how does that come about?
We find this identity in Christ, we see that we're saints
and we're children of God,
but how is that brought about in our lives?
How did it happen in Ephesus?
Well, there's lots that could be said here,
but I wanna focus on a couple of things.
I want us to see that God brings this about
by His word and by His will.
So Paul was involved in their conversion
and in their ongoing growth in Christ,
but he doesn't take credit for it here.
He makes it clear that God is the one
who's brought this about.
He was the human instrument, but this is the Lord's work
and he worked through His word and through His will.
So where do we see that?
Well, verse one, so let's see what Paul says
about himself.
It's just Paul an apostle of Jesus Christ
by the will of God.
So the word of God, Paul is riding
with the authority of an apostle.
So the apostles, just so we were all on the same page here,
the apostles were disciples.
He would been uniquely set apart
and then sent out by Jesus with authority
to proclaim His word.
They were the authoritative witnesses of His resurrection.
When they spoke, they spoke with the authority of Christ
as His sort of official representatives in the world.
And we'll see later on in Ephesians
that they kind of laid the foundation of the church.
The church is built on their teaching, their doctrine.
And that same foundation is laid before us today
in scripture, including the book of Ephesians.
As Paul writes with this apostolic authority.
And Paul's journey to becoming an apostle began
in the least likely of places.
I'd love to take more time to just look
at Paul's testimony.
But go read it in Acts chapter nine.
He began as a religious leader,
a persecutor of the church.
And then while he was one day on the way to arrest Christians,
he met the risen Christ suddenly on the roads to Damascus.
And we read about how Jesus personally commissioned him
to be an apostle.
His life was changed and he's seen the risen Christ.
And now he's to speak as his representative
and go proclaiming His name throughout the world.
And so his apostolic ministry like the others
was revolving around seeing Christ
and then speaking His word, proclaiming His gospel.
And so what results from the preaching of the gospel?
Well, people being united to Christ.
That's what happens in Ephesus.
The word of God goes out
and when Luke summarizes what happens
when he writes the book of Acts,
when he summarizes what took place in Ephesus,
he doesn't say Paul's plans prevailed.
He doesn't say, you know,
the church did an amazing job really getting the word out.
Here's what he says, Acts chapter 19 and verse 20.
Here's the summary of everything that took place in Ephesus.
So the word of the Lord
continued to increase and prevailed mightily.
It is the living word of God
that accomplishes the work of God in our lives.
And so Paul is now writing this letter
with the anticipation that they are going to experience
the grace and peace of God
through the word that he's writing to them,
showing them who they are in Christ.
So how do we receive this new identity,
this new life in Christ?
Romans 10, 17, so then faith comes by hearing
and hearing by the word of God.
First Peter chapter one, verse 23,
you have been born again not of perishable seed,
but of imperishable through the living
and enduring word of God.
God brings about new life in Christ
through the preaching of the gospel.
It is through hearing his word that he opens our eyes,
he opens our hearts to see Christ for who he is.
It's through that that gives us new life in him.
How do we learn to live in step with who we are
in Christ while we're gonna spend a lot of time
looking at that in this book.
But it's through hearing the word.
Second Timothy 3, 16 says that scripture
equips us for every good work.
So God gives us new life and growth by his word.
You know the German reformer Martin Luther,
very involved in the Protestant Reformation.
And there's this huge work that went on
of people coming to see that salvation is by grace alone,
through faith alone and Christ alone.
And so later in his life,
he spoke about his involvement
in now what is known as the Protestant Reformation.
And here's what he said about his involvement in it.
He says, humbly, I simply taught,
I preached God's word,
otherwise I did nothing.
And while I slept or drank Wittenberg beer with my friends,
I did nothing.
The word did everything.
Here's what happened.
I let the word loose and God did the work
and I rested in him.
We wanna see people come to know Christ
to be given this new life, this new identity in him.
We wanna see the church growing in his likeness.
Well, how will that happen?
It will happen through the proclamation of the word.
So by God's grace, may this be a place
where his word is preached,
where we speak the truth to one another in love
and where we go out to the world to make Christ known.
But it's not only by the word of God,
it's also by the will of God,
by the will of God that we receive this new identity.
And we'll look at this more over the next couple of weeks.
But notice that Paul says he's an apostle
by the will of God.
This work that Paul was doing
wasn't the kind of result of vocational goal setting.
He didn't have his kind of vision bored
with all of his dreams pinned on
and he's just kind of marking them off one at a time,
hoping to be an apostle one day.
Like we saw a second ago,
like he was heading in one direction
and God completely turned him around
in the other direction, right?
This wasn't on the table before,
now him proclaiming Christ.
So God's will is why he's an apostle.
God made him an apostle.
And God's will is now being carried out
as he continues in this work.
His calling didn't come with all the details mapped out.
The maps in the back of your Bible, if you've got one,
weren't drawn before he went out.
They were drawn after.
And sometimes he went to places
where the door was opened.
Other times he went places
and found that the door was closed.
But every time he trusted that God was still at work,
accomplishing his will,
what he wanted to see happen.
And so when Paul is referring to God's will here,
he's talking about his,
you could say the will of decree.
It's the, to put it more simply,
it's the unfolding of his plans in our lives
and in the world around us.
And that's how this church in Ephesus started.
It's God's will that unfolded there
as his word was proclaimed.
And so that's what we heard in the reading
earlier, which Luke helpfully pointed out.
Paul initially preached there
and he says, I've got to go elsewhere
and I will return if the Lord wills.
And so I'll come back here if that's what the Lord wants,
if that is his plan.
Of course, it was the Lord's plan
and this church happened as a result.
So how do we come to be in Christ?
If you are in Christ,
it's because the Lord Himself saw to it
that you were in a place where you heard his word.
It may have been from parents,
it may have been from grandparents
or a Sunday school teacher or a friend.
The Lord brought you his word by his will
and he brought you into faith in Jesus Christ.
You are in Christ because God by his grace
was pleased to unite you to him
and his death and resurrection.
It was his will, his plan that was being accomplished
in your life.
And as we look to the future, we can trust that
he will guide us to accomplish his purposes in the world.
That's true individually and collectively.
So let's apply it to Trinity Fellowship.
This church isn't here because of some great plan
that we've hatched
and the steps we're planning to take
over the next few months,
aren't gonna be executed perfectly
by any stretch of the means.
Mistakes will be made, let me warn you.
But the growth of the birth and the growth of this church
we trust will ultimately come about
according to the will of God,
according to his good pleasure.
Julie and I recently were able to go on a trip
to Montana to this marriage retreat
and it was really refreshing.
We've never done anything like that before.
And one of the most refreshing things that was said to us
right at the start was when we were in the car,
there was another couple who were in the car
and then there was someone who was driving
and somebody said in the car, they said,
oh, this is so nice to not have to figure out
where we're going.
Like I would have no idea how to get out to the cabin
or make my way through Montana.
And the driver said this, they said,
well, this is why we're here.
We're here so that you don't have to make
any decisions this week.
We've been doing this for years.
We know how to get to where we're going.
We've got the schedule all laid out for you.
All you have to do is just come with us.
And it was really wonderful.
Now, if you didn't trust them,
it might have not worked out great.
But these were people we trusted.
All we had to do was just get in the car
and trusted that they knew what they were doing.
We could trust in their plans.
Now, being in Christ and being confident in his will
doesn't mean that we don't have decisions to make
or things to do.
I'm not saying that,
but it does mean that as we move forward,
we can do so trusting that we are secure in Christ,
that we have a Heavenly Father
who is working out his good plans in our lives
and in the church and in this community.
And that is true whether our plans work out
or whether they do not.
He is accomplishing his will.
And he knows what is best.
So let's dream, let's plan, let's work,
let's hold all of that with an open hand
and say, this we will do if the Lord wills.
Let's move forward confidently
knowing that we are secure in Jesus.
No, we're not in the world to discover
and to express our authentic selves,
but we are here to know Christ and to proclaim him.
And so now we are gonna come
to the Lord's table together in communion
and hear Christ's death force proclaimed
in the elements there.
We've been speaking about our union with Christ.
And our union with Christ is the source
of our communion with him and with one another as well,
our fellowship.
And the Lord has given us this meal
to celebrate that union and communion with him.
Last week we saw how baptism represents
being united to him in his death and in his resurrection.
And similarly, this meal symbolizes his death
and the bread symbolizes his body that was broken for us
and the wine symbolizes his blood that was shed for us.
And this is a family meal.
And so through our participation in it,
we are together remembering our Lord's sacrificial death.
We are enjoying communion with him and with one another.
And we are, according to his instructions,
proclaiming his death until he returns.
So just a few words of instruction
as we come to this table.
In a few moments we're gonna sing
and during that time as we're singing,
feel free to come forward at any point
to take a piece of the bread and to dip it into the wine.
And just so you know as well,
the wine is non-alcoholic
and over to my left, to your right,
there's a gluten-free option there if that is needed.
But if you're trusting in Christ
for the forgiveness of your sins
and you have publicly identified with him in baptism,
then I'd invite you to partake with us
in this meal together, remembering Jesus' death for us.
But if that's not you, if you're not sure
whether or not you are in Christ,
whether or not you're following him,
I would ask you to refrain from taking this,
but to at the same time ponder
and prayerfully consider the message
that is being proclaimed through it,
Jesus' death for us.
And hear the invitation to come to him by faith.
So as we take this time to remember Jesus' death,
let's pause and take a moment to pray
before we come to this table.
I'm going to be now praising your great name
for all that you have done for us in Christ.
As we come to your table,
we want to especially thank you
for his sacrificial and substitutionary death
for us on the cross.
He took our sin that we might be made saints.
He was forsaken that we might be welcomed as family.
So as we partake in this bread and wine,
help us to receive it by faith
and with thanksgiving in Jesus' name.
Amen.